we have a voicemail today about
universal basic income our voicemail
number is two one nine two david p you
can call any time of day whenever you
want I don't mind it's just the
answering machine and here is a
voicemail about my recent interview with
Andrew yang 2020 Democratic presidential
candidate about ubi hey David somebody
had Andrew hanging on not too long ago
talking about his UPI plan but it seems
to me I just don't know that
what twelve thousand dollars a year
would really do for a lot of people I
think it seems like like it's great for
someone who's saying making $20,000 a
year at a minimum wage job right because
then they go from twenty to thirty two
and that's a pretty nice bump but if
you're someone who has nothing but that
obviously to a thousand starts better
than nothing but you're still in poverty
right here still gonna struggle to pay
rent you know the big that's and
especially because s res podcast
engineering said that his ubi would be
opt-in and if you opt in then you can no
longer get things like food stamps so I
just think like a lot of people need it
the most are gonna end up kind of at a
loss yeah these are all reasonable
concerns about universal basic income
individually they all have different
answers depending on how you configure
the system but I think even for people
you know the caller said if you make
nothing and you get twelve thousand
dollars you're still in poverty
well yes but now a twenty thousand
dollar a year job in addition to the
twelve thousand does get you thirty two
thousand dollars a year so I I share a
lot of these concerns I just don't think
that these are the specific reasons why
ubi will or won't work I think that
there's just broader picture issues
which I brought up with Andrew yang
about negative income income taxes
versus ubi does ubi add on to other
social welfare programs or does it
replace it every single ubi proposal
answers those questions in a slightly
different way every one of those
concerns is legitimate but I don't think
they are actually the biggest questions
around universal basic income we have a
great bonus show
coming up for you today Donald Trump now
says windmills are bird killers
technically true but he over states the
importance of it as he tries to revive
the coal industry I 95 one of the main
East Coast highways is finally done
after 60 years but now you have to start
the repairs because a lot of those parts
now really need some help and we will
discuss whether Melania Trump is
trolling her husband with her entire
anti-bullying campaign david pakman.com
slash membership or patreon.com slash
david pakman show two places where you
can become a supporter of the show and
then as a result get instant access to
the bonus show I look forward to
speaking to you on that Members Only
bonus show in mere minutes